[موسيقى]
حاولنا يكون معنا الدكتور عبدالله القويس
في لقاء مباشر من جبل فلسطين يمكن لكن
الاتصال لم نستطيع ذلك نحاول نشوف نقدر
خلينا نشوف الان اذا كان يطلع معنا
الدكتور عبد الله دكتور عبد الله
يا مرحبا يا دكتور حياك الله الحمد لله
على السلامه نقول
الله يسلمك ويطول عمرك طمني عليك وين وصلت
ممتاز
ممتاز وين وصلت قبل قبل 30 دقيقه تقول انك
وصلت
مخيم بيسكامب
البيس كامل اللي هو المخيم الرئيسي هذا
وين هذا وكم يبلغ ارتفاعه
بحدود 5400 ما شاء الله تبارك الله كيف
كيف التجربه دكتور عبد الله
وين الصعوبه مقارنه بكلمنجارو
دكتور تسمعني
وين الصعوبه مقارنه
اطول
ايفرست صعوبه في اليوم الاخير لكن هذا
يعني من تقريبا اليوم
يبدا عندك
والبرد برد الشديد
لكن المناظر جميله للغايه
وما ممكن تشوف
مواهب طبيعيه الا في هذا المكان
مغطاه
الى ان ترتفع الى مستوى معين بعد 3000
3,500 تبدا الاشجار
بهذا الارتفاع ولا ناوي تكمل وين توصل
الى نقطه التي ينطلق منها المحترفون الذين
يصلون الى القمه
انت ناوي توصل
من الناس اللي وصلوا اليه وصلوا لها خمسه
وامراتين
انت انت الان في اي مرحله من من رحلتك
دكتور
لا خلاص وصلنا خلاص
هذه النهايه
دكتور عبد الله لما وصلت الى هذا المكان
الى هذه القمه في هذا الارتفاع
وما كانوا يتوقع انه انه
في هذا السن الحمد لله
بقياده
وصل الى القمه الكبير
وكيف استطعت تتكيف مع كل التحديات
والعوائق والبرد الشديد دكتور وانت في
هالسن
تعلم نفسك
ان شاء الله رحله جايه
اسمعك يا خالد
الله يحييك الله يحييك الرحله الجايه ان
شاء الله الشهر الجاي
ما شاء الله عليك الشهر الجاي على طول يا
دكتور طيب اصبر ارتاح شوي يعني
اكبر سعودي وعربي وصل لهذه القمه هذا هو
هذه الرساله وهذا الانجاز اللي تبغى توصل
له ولا في اهداف لا لا
بس الواحد يعني
يحرك
ويبتعد عن الخمول
حاول يشوف ثقافات جديده واماكن جديده
مختلفه
يعني
اللي شفته في هذه الديره اشياء غريبه يعني
ناحيه ثانيه
يبدو انه هذه صايره موضح حكايه
فوجدت افواج من الناس تقريبا 70 80% منهم
هنود
يبدو انها صايره يعني موضه
يمكن بعد الكورونا يعني
لكن التجربه تستحق صراحه التجربه هذه كمان
تستحق لقاء مطول لانه تجربه مختلفه واكيد
يعني احنا موعودين ان شاء الله اننا نقف
على كل تفاصيلها
وصولا ان شاء الله حتى وصولك الى الى
المملكه كل التوفيق لك دكتور نزول امن
وسهله
ومبروك مبروك هذا الانجاز وهذا النجاح
اللي مثلنا جميعا والله يا دكتور يعطيك
الف عافيه
شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات